te encuentras disfrutando de un
concierto de rock pero te encuentras muy
cerca de las bocinas y como que el
volumen alto te comienza a molestar
necesitas un descanso así que te diriges
aquí atrás y mi pregunta es
quizás parezca una pregunta algo tonta
aunque realmente no lo es mi pregunta es
porque pareciera que el sonido es más
suave cuando estamos más lejos de la
bocina que cuando estamos cerca y aquí
hay que tener cuidado porque hay dos
razones diferentes para esto y tenemos
que ser muy claros a qué nos referimos
no es una pregunta tan tonta aquí
tenemos la bocina y voy a representar la
onda de sonido con este círculo y para
mantenerlo simple digamos que este es un
solo sonido no es algo que se esté
repitiendo este es un impulso de sonido
y es como luce una onda en cierto
momento del tiempo tenemos este frente
de onda y si esperamos lo suficiente
vamos a ver que este frente de onda va a
emanar de esta manera
este es el frente de onda si esperamos
un poco más de tiempo y si esperamos un
poco más nuestra onda de sonido podría
verse así
esta es la misma onda que se va
ampliando conforme pasa el tiempo es la
misma onda solo que vista en diferentes
momentos del tiempo y la pregunta es
para recordarlo porque si una persona
está aquí cerca de la bocina va a
escuchar el sonido mucho más alto de lo
que lo escucharía una persona que se
encuentra más alejada una de las razones
por las que esto ocurre es debido a la
intensidad y la intensidad se define
como la potencia
potencia
entre el área
área
por lo que esta bocina genera cierta
potencia que va a estar repartida en
esta área pero esta onda de sonido se va
a propagar hacia un área más grande aquí
alrededor por lo que ahora esta misma
cantidad de potencia se encuentra
repartido en una área mucho más grande y
esto continúa y mientras más tiempo pasa
esa misma potencia se va a repartir en
un área cada vez más grande
como por ejemplo esto de aquí
y esta es una de las razones por las que
sucede esto
si nosotros dividimos la misma cantidad
de potencia entre un área más grande
vamos a tener una intensidad mucho más
pequeña y nuestro oído no registra toda
la onda que se esparce en esta área
nuestro oído solo registra aquella parte
de la onda que les llega o que nos llega
justo al oído si nuestro oído pudiera
registrar toda la potencia que se
encuentra aquí en esta área
quizás escucharemos la misma intensidad
que si estamos más cerca pero solo
detectamos una parte así es que solo
podemos percibir qué tan concentrada es
esa intensidad y no la cantidad total de
sonido que se encuentra en toda la
superficie así que qué tanto va a
disminuir esta intensidad conforme nos
alejamos imaginemos que esta persona se
encuentra a esta distancia que le vamos
a llamar d
y esta otra persona se encuentra el
doble de la distancia de vamos a
dibujarlo más o menos así
esto es aquí es 2 de el doble de esta
distancia si esta persona escucha la
intensidad y cuál será la intensidad que
alcanza a escuchar la persona que se
encuentra hasta acá será la mitad de una
cuarta parte de ahí bueno para
calcularla tenemos que recordar que
estas ondas de sonidos se dispersan en
un área tridimensional por lo que en
realidad estas son superficies esféricas
por lo que tenemos que recordar cuál es
el área de una esfera y yo si me acuerdo
cuál es el área de una esfera el área es
igual a 4 x pi por radio al cuadrado
entonces nuestra intensidad va a ser
igual a la potencia
la potencia dividida entre esta área que
es 4 por pi por radio al cuadrado y si
tenemos a esta persona que está al doble
de distancia que ésta quiere decir que
el radio de aquí va a ser el doble que
este otro así que no va a tener el doble
del área recuerden que esta ere el radio
se eleva al cuadrado así que vamos a
tener cuatro veces el área que teníamos
aquí así que esta misma potencia se va a
propagar
en un área cuatro veces mayor por lo que
esta intensidad va a ser una cuarta
parte de lo que era en este punto y si
nos alejáramos tres veces esta distancia
cuál sería la intensidad en este punto
de aquí pues tendremos tres veces este
radio al cuadrado entonces será nueve
veces el área original por lo que aquí
tendremos un noveno de la intensidad
original así que aquí tenemos una regla
importante la intensidad va a ser
proporcional a 1 / r al cuadrado muchas
cosas en física son proporcionales a 1 /
real cuadrado y la intensidad del sonido
es una de ellas ya que esta onda de
sonido se propaga en una área esférica
que va a ser tan grande como r al
cuadrado y aunque simplificado esta es
una de las razones por las que
escuchamos el sonido más suave cuando
nos alejamos
la misma potencia se va a estar
esparciendo o propagando en un área cada
vez más grande conforme pasa el tiempo y
esta es una simplificación porque una
bocina difícilmente va a estar
propagando ondas perfectamente esféricas
lo cual tiene sentido porque si nosotros
construimos una bocina realmente no
vamos a querer que el sonido se vaya
hacia aquí atrás queremos que el sonido
se proyecte hacia adelante pero esto
realmente no importa aunque aquí no
tenga una esfera perfecta vamos a tener
una parte de una esfera y el sonido se
va a propagar en una parte de una esfera
estas van a seguir siendo ondas de
sonido tridimensionales
aunque el sonido o la potencia más bien
no se va a esparcir en un área
exactamente de 4 pipo radio al cuadrado
quizás sea una tercera parte de la
esfera o quizá en una octava parte o
quizá en una dieciseisava parte esto no
importa lo que importa es que aquí vamos
a seguir teniendo el real cuadrado por
lo que la intensidad del sonido va a
seguir siendo la potencia entre algo que
tiene r al cuadrado por lo que la
intensidad sigue siendo proporcional a 1
/ r al cuadrado
regresemos a nuestro ejemplo anterior en
donde explicamos una de las razones por
las que el sonido se escucha más suave
mientras más lejos está de la fuente ya
que se propaga en un área mayor y la
segunda razón es que bueno aquí quizás
no dije toda la verdad en cuanto a que
no toda la potencia va a llegar a la
persona que está escuchando mucha de esa
potencia se va a ir por otras partes
mucha de esa potencia se va a perder en
el aire que se encuentra aquí aunque
realmente no me gusta el término perdido
porque sabemos dónde está pero cuando
uno dice que hay pérdida de energía
normalmente se refiere a que se
transforma en energía térmica
en las moléculas de aire que están
flotando por aquí así que no es que esté
perdida simplemente es que no está
disponible se pierde en las vibraciones
térmicas de las moléculas de aire y aquí
no me refiero a las oscilaciones
coordinadas hacia adelante y hacia atrás
que es la forma en la que se propaga el
sonido en el aire me refiero a las
vibraciones aleatorias que van en
cualquier dirección
esto le quita energía a las ondas de
sonido y esta es otra razón por la que
la persona que se encuentra más alejada
va a escuchar el sonido más suave de lo
que lo escucha la persona que se
encuentra más cercana no solo porque la
potencia se va a estar repartiendo en
una área más grande sino porque también
algo de esa energía se va a perder y
esto tiene un nombre en particular se
les llama atenuación
atenuación
y la atenuación se refiere al hecho de
que parte de esta energía se pierde en
el medio en donde se propaga la onda así
que siempre que el medio absorba energía
de la onda que se está propagando en él
vamos a tener atenuación y estas son las
dos razones independientes por las que
se suaviza el sonido conforme nos
alejamos de la fuente una es porque la
potencia de la onda se va a repartir en
una área cada vez más grande conforme
hacia el eje y la otra es porque la
energía de la onda se va a perder un
poco en el medio en donde se está
propagando por lo que algo de esa
energía ni siquiera va a llegar a donde
estemos debido a la atenuación